er gehört zu den gefährlichsten
asteroiden die es gibt ja so in 2009 10
as 3 könnte am 16 september 2084 mit der
erde kollidieren mit einer größe von 14
metern hat er knapp die größe des
asteroiden der 2013 in der nähe von
tscheljabinsk in der atmosphäre
explodiert ist ein solcher brocken hat
das potenzial bei einem direkten
einschlag eine großstadt zu zerstören
pixum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur dann verpasste nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen erst im
vergangenen monat im september 2009 10
hatte die europäische weltraumagentur
esa berichtet dass es derzeit 878 es zu
jedem bekannt sind die die erde in den
kommenden 100 jahren treffen könnt jetzt
ist ein weiterer potenziell gefährlicher
brocken mit auf diese risiko liste
kommen der astrid mit der bezeichnung
2009 csu 3 könnte schon in 65 jahren mit
einer distanz von knapp 120 tausend
kilometern auf kollisionskurs mit der
erde gehen
die chance dass der etwa eben 14 meter
große brocken am 16 september 2084 die
erde trifft liegt medienberichten
zufolge bei genau 1 252 damit gehört er
zu den vier objekten bei denen einen
einschlag auf der erde
am wahrscheinlichsten ist ja und
mittlerweile sind auf der liste sogar
886 asteroiden aufgeführt das ist der
stand vom 10 10 die der erde potenziell
gefährlich werden könnten und es kommen
ständig neue objekte hinzu aber nicht so
gefährlich wie 2009 csu drei der neu
aufgenommen gebrochen gehört wohl mit zu
den gefährlichsten objekten seiner art
deswegen hält die esa dieses objekt also
jetzt ganz besonders scharf unter
beobachtung auch wenn die bisher
prognostizierte distanz von 120.000
kilometern beim vorbeiflug zunächst
einmal nach einer großen distanz klingt
handelt es sich in astronomischen
maßstäben gedacht um peanuts astronomie
teams haben analysiert dass der brocken
derzeit keineswegs gefährlich ist da er
noch auf einer weiten bahn um die erde
zieht doch dabei kreuzte die
umlaufbahnen andere
planeten unter anderem die umlaufbahn
des merkurs des mars und der venus und
genau das könnte dann letztendlich seine
flugbahn verändern und ihn auf genau den
kollisionskurs mit der erde bringen die
gravitationskraft eines anderen planeten
könnte in dem brocken also gewissermaßen
den entscheidenden schubs geben der ihn
dann auf direktem weg in richtung erde
katapultiert fachleute weltweit
analysieren nun welche ausmaße seinen
anschlag auf der erde hätte da der
brocken mit einem durchmesser von zehn
metern eher zu den kleineren objekten
gehört ist es gut möglich dass er in der
erdatmosphäre verbrennt und gar nicht
auf der erde aufprallt zum direkten
vergleich der erst 2013 nähe des ural
gebirges eingeschlagen war hatte einen
durchmesser von 20 metern und wog etwa
16.000 tonnen
dennoch wurden rund 1500 menschen
verletzt und 700 gebäude beschädigt
falls 2009 10 as 3 tatsächlich die erde
treffen sollte rechnen fachleute derzeit
also nicht mit einer globalen
katastrophe
doch spätestens seit dem vorfall in der
nähe des ural gebirges bereiten sich
forschungsteams auf den worst case for
wir berichten hier ja bei gigs in
science fiction immer wieder darüber
unter anderem wird an methoden
gearbeitet an möglichen
asteroideneinschlag frühzeitig
abzuwenden stichwort emma das steht für
hyper velocity es rollt mit migration
mission for emergency response vehikel
damit soll menü der nach einschätzung
der nasa einer der gefährlichsten hast
du ihnen überhaupt ist möglicherweise
weg geschubst werden denn dieser brocken
könnte am 25 september 2001 135 der erde
tatsächlich gefährlich nahe kommen und
das hätte mit einem durchmesser von 500
metern und einem gewicht von 87
millionen tonnen fatale folgen beim
aufprall würde er nach berechnungen der
nasa wurde eine energie von 80.000
atombomben freisetzen das entspricht
einer kinetischen energie von 1200
megatonnen tnt die behörde namens
planetary die fans team der nasa plant
das neun meter lange und knapp neun
tonnen schwere raumschiff mit einer
delta 4 heavy in den weltraum zu bringen
es könnte nicht nur als transportmittel
für eine atombombe dienen sondern eben
auch als rammbock für bendel
denn ein kleiner schubser könnten
ihn zu einer kursänderung bringen und
selbst wenn diese erst mal nur minimal
wäre könnte sie den kurs mit einer
gewissen vorlaufzeit im laufe der zeit
immer weiter verschieben doch bis dahin
ist noch viel arbeit denn weder das
raumschiff wurde bislang gebaut noch
wurden die missionen oder flugzeit
geplant neben solchen plänen plädieren
experten experten zudem immer wieder für
eine bessere weltweite zusammenarbeit
und den aufbau eines koordinierten
frühwarnsystems denn das ist mehr als
ausbaufähig durchflog beispielsweise der
hast du eben 2009/10 ok erst ende juli
unbemerkt an der erde vorbei fachleuten
zufolge bei dieser brocken fast aus dem
nichts gekommen und dennoch ist er in
einer distanz von nur 72 1499 kilometern
an der erde vorbei gerauscht die esa
plant im kommenden jahr ein neues
teleskop auf sizilien aufzubauen um den
nachthimmel nach objekten abzusuchen ein
solches teleskop würde es innerhalb von
maximal vier nächten schaffen den himmel
nach potenziell gefährlichen objekten ab
zu scannen um diese in einer nacht zu
schaffen bräuchte ist allerdings drei
bis vier solcher teleskope klar ist
einfach die erde ist ständig bedroht von
kollisionen mit erdnahen asteroiden
viele objekte sind klein und verglühen
in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es
bemerken dass ein himmelskörper in die
atmosphäre eindringt und explodiert oder
einschickt kommt allerdings öfter vor
als wir denken es ist also nur eine
frage der zeit bis ein asteroid auf die
erde trifft 2022 plant die nasa deswegen
mit der daad mission die erste planetare
verteidigungs mission überhaupt dort
steht für double es redirection test und
die nasa will mit diesem manöver ein
spektakuläres und neuartiges asteroiden
abwehr verfahren testen das ziel wird
der erdnahe doppel hast du ihn 6 5 803
sein ein doppel körper deswegen auch der
name die muss so heißt der die
griechische bezeichnung für zwillinge
die flugbahn änderung des kleineren
objekten namens dee dee moore soll durch
die 500 kilogramm schwerer raumsonde tat
ausgelöst werden die dem nasa plan
zufolge am 17 oktober 2022 mit sechs
kilometern pro stunde auf stehen hast du
jeden treffen soll
der aufprall würde nach den berechnungen
der nasa eine veränderung der bahn
geschwindigkeit von dämonen um etwa 0,4
millimeter pro sekunde bewirken auch
wenn das zunächst nach einer kleinen
minimalen verändern klingt wäre solch
eine neuausrichtung groß genug um sie
mit teleskopen von der erde aus zu
messen dieses manöver würde zeigen ob
wir mit solch einer mission tatsächlich
auch einen asteroiden der sich auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde befindet
erfolgreich um lenken können denn fest
steht schon eine kleine flugbahn
änderung eines asteroiden könnte das
fortbestehen der erde sicherstellen
objekt aus einer fremden welt traf die
erde von neugier zone sehr spannendes
video anklicken anschauen oder auf jeden
fall neugierig und abonnieren
für noch mehr wissenschaft bis dann
bleibt dran